have experiences Live Lean so that you
can have choices and you know indulge in
your creativity and your curiosity we
frame this backwards in the sense that
when I have enough money or when I
retire or when I have the the luxury of
time then I will indulge that you know
instinct to go see the world when in
truth when you don't have money and you
have tons of time that's the time to do
it and we think we can't afford it but
there are incredibly cheap ways to do
this it's truly you know experience and
broadening your horizons and finding a
way to contribute and link your life
path to some kind of purpose or meaning
that extends beyond your ego and kind of
you know self-gratifying instincts that
you will find the happiness that all
those other false promises fail to
deliver on